ein klappmesser einen schlagstock und
einen tritt in den rücken dieses video
hier schockiert die täter sind zwölf und
13 jahre als kinder misshandeln kinder
dieser brutale clip kursiert aktuell im
internet rund zwei minuten lang ist er
verteilt sich rasend schnelle sind zwei
kinder zu sehen die zwei andere mehrmals
schlagen bedrohen demütigen es fallen
schimpfwörter es ist ein schlag gegen
stand zu sehen sogar ein gezücktem
messer und fassbar der übergriff
geschichten müssen am tag in weinheim in
baden württemberg eine kleine stadt die
passanten und die gehen einfach vorbei
greifen nicht ein niemand hilft den
opfern
und wir haben mit roland kern dem
pressesprecher von weinheim gesprochen
kriminelle muss man glaube ich auch so
ganz kippen klar sagen kriminelle
qualität und deshalb ist die polizei da
der richtige adressat die polizei hat
sich des falles angenommen und ist dort
auch den richtigen händen das wird auch
der staatsanwaltschaft übergeben und
diese kinder werden doch
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln zur
rechenschaft gezogen dass das was wir
tun können und wir schalten jetzt zu
carsten stahl der in schulen geht und
die morgentraining abhält herr stark
erschüttert sie dieses video von den
jugendlichen aus weinheim
ja erstmal schönen tag ja natürlich
erschüttert mich dass jedes mal das
wieder zu sehen aber ich möchte hier
gleich eins klarstellen weil das sehr
schnell auch politisch immer so heißt es
sind bedauerliche einzelfälle es sind
keine einzelfälle
ich habe tagtäglich mit solchen fällen
zu tun denken wir an den fall von einer
in dem ihr auch bundesweit im bild am
sonntag geschrieben habt wo ein junge in
der schule zusammengeschlagen wurde um
zu sehen ob er daran stirbt auch das war
unser fall oder denken wir an
heiligenhafen wo sich vor anderthalb
wochen junge an der bushaltestelle
erhängt hat und das von anderen gefilmt
wurde und es öffentlich gemacht wurde
das sind keine einzelfälle
das ist die realität
und das passiert deshalb weil man
einfach kein respekt und keine toleranz
mehr vermittelt und schulen ganz
besonders schulen lieber mobbing und
gewalt an den schulen tot schweigen
anstatt aufklärung und prävention zu
machen und weil die bilder oft die
eltern gar nicht mehr
um die kinder zu kümmern die sein müsste
und ihnen das auch nicht vorleben was
das bedeutet was ich hier sehe ist
erniedrigung ist mobbing ist gewalt aber
ist täglicher alltag mittlerweile an
schulen in deutschland und es ist keine
einbahnstraße ich kann ihn
hundertprozentig garantieren dass auch
die hier die opfer die kinder die jetzt
opfer einer die mieten waren das auch
schon getan haben vielleicht zu anderen
die kleiner sind es ist eine
gruppendynamik ein gruppenzwang der sich
immer wieder rotieren
ernährt und wissen was erschreckende ist
die dies verhindern könnten die
erwachsenen die gehen einfach vorbei sie
schauen nicht hin sie wollen damit
nichts zu tun haben sie schauen feige
weg und dann wenn es dann passiert ist
dann hörst du irgendwelche
pressesprecher aufschreien und sagen wir
werden irgendwas machen wo macht denn
diese stadt oder anderen städte wirklich
etwas gegen mobbing und gewalt an den
schulen alles lippenbekenntnisse ich
mache derzeit noch in jahren hatte über
100.000 schüler bundesweit an über 300
schulen das hier ist traurige realität
und sorry wenn das sehr wütend berichtet
sie weil man muss den kindern das
erklären man muss ihnen vor man muss ihm
vorbildern sein weil das hier geht sonst
immer weiter immer weiter jetzt geht es
darum darüber zu reden ja aber ganz
schnell wird der deckel des schweigens
draus gemacht und dann machen wir weiter
wie immer wir wollen das verändern denn
müssen wir anfragen in der gesellschaft
an den schulen und in der politik die
seit vielen jahrzehnten sich diesem
thema nicht annimmt die
gewaltbereitschaft die brutalität und
die hemmschwellen der jugendlichen wird
immer geringer und durch die panini hat
sich das alles noch 58 er starrt man
merkte das thema beschäftigt nicht nur
sie das ist wirklich ein sehr brutales
video was wir sehen und sie sagen das
ist kein einzelfall das kommt häufiger
vor was fordern sie ganz konkret von den
schulen oder vielleicht auch von der
politik was muss sich ändern
als allererstes man kann das doch nur
bekämpfen sie sehen das ja hier warum
gehen die passanten vorbei sie wollen
damit nichts zu tun haben und an den
schulen ist es oft so dass lehrer erst
gar nicht dazu ausgebildet sind auch gar
nicht wissen wie sie damit umgehen
sollen und leider auch wegsehen oft und
wenn lehrer wegsehen wenn passanten
wegsehen signalisieren wir der jugend es
ist okay sie können so weiter machen sie
können immer weiter fahren
wir müssen aufklären wir müssen
prävention machen wir müssen geld in die
hand nehmen für die jugend denn sie sind
die zukunft wir müssen der politik
klarmachen dass es nicht nur um die
mainstream themen geht sondern vor allen
dingen auch unsere jugend ja und wenn
man dann solche fälle hat es wären sie
gerne als bedauerliche einzelfälle
dargestellt um ganz schnell wieder den
deckel des schweigens drauf zu machen
wir müssen prävention fördern wir müssen
dieses thema ernst nehmen das ist hier
nur ein fall ich könnte ihnen stehen so
ne videos zu schicken wo sogar ein
messer in den hals eines anderen
gestochen wurde ja dass hier was jetzt
hier ist ist traurig die kinder sind zum
glück verpixelt aber das muss jetzt das
mutter muss aufgegriffen werden nicht
nur in dieser stadt das ist in jeder
stadt ein thema selbst in den kleinsten
gebieten wird das immer ein thema
aufklärung prävention offenheit und die
hälfte aller schulleiter in deutschland
sagt an unserer schule gibt es kein
mobbing die haben keine gewalt keine
probleme und dann sage ich immer ja ja
die beschreitung eure kinder schweißen
und kurzen rosenduft wenn wir nicht
aufhören mit dieser lüge und hat ganz
deutlich jede schulleitung wie in
deutschland sagt an ihrer schule gibt es
kein mobbing und keine gewalt die
lügt weil sie angst hat als
problemschule dazustehen und weil sie
ganz wichtig vor den ministerien und den
schüler dann vollkommen überfordert
damit im stich gelassen wird und das
muss aufhören wir reden im bundestag
darüber in landtage abgeordnetenhäuser
wir haben darüber schon
2018 in berlin gesprochen 2020 in
brandenburg im landtag und 2020 auch im
sachsenland tag was glauben sie ist
seitdem passiert nachdem viele experten
gesagt hat wir müssen eingreifen nichts
ist passiert man hört sich an man macht
den deckel drauf und machen noch munter
weil prävention sondern das ist ganz
ganz wichtig herzlichen dank für diese
einordnung an karsten stahl
gewaltprävention trainer